hello miles congratulations on this and
wow on top gun i still can't believe we
have a sequel to that movie that is that
exceptional thank you thank you i
appreciate it i appreciate all that all
right so first question on this one is
obviously about your collaboration with
joseph three films in now so what is
something about the way you two work
together on all three films that has
stayed consistent and then what's
something he did on spider head that you
know surprised you and maybe you didn't
even realize he was capable of as a
director well i i think with joe we're
just i i think we
i think we meshed pretty pretty quickly
on only the brave i think
that happened because i just really
trusted him i i think that
from looking at his other work you know
that everything behind the camera is is
going to be taken care of you know that
visually
whatever's on screen is going to be very
interesting and i think that's really
joe's sweet spot is kind of creating
these worlds
um obviously with top gun
and and spider head it's a little more i
think in in that pocket only the brave
was just so gritty and so naturalistic
and really
you know dealing it with that
but um
yeah i just don't think joe
can really offend me at this point and i
i think it goes i think it goes
the same way i just think that we're
really i mean at this point we're just
really good friends and and so that i
think that makes the working part of it
a lot easier
stick with him you two have quite the
track record together no i know i'm not
letting him get away so i was reading a
quote that he gave in the production
notes how uh this entire ensemble here
basically raised each other's games
throughout the entire process so given
how many scenes you share with chris
what's something that you really
appreciated about him as a scene partner
that maybe even brought something out of
your own performance that you didn't
even realize you were capable of
i mean chris is just he's really just a
gamer i i think that the more
stuff outside of thor that that he does
and people are able to see i think
they'll really start to
speak about him as just a great actor
not as not as a
you know thor superhero any of that
stuff and those parts are really hard to
do having a little having dabbled in it
a little bit with all the green screen
that's that's really tough
and i think
chris is just he can do whatever he
wants man there's there's not a single
performance that he's not capable of and
and he absolutely raised my game very
very much believe in what you just said
all right so for you now this seems like
the ultimate acting challenge and a very
unique one at that so what would you say
is the biggest difference between how
you approach a scene when the emotion
comes about i guess more organically
versus how it operates here where
someone pushes a button and you got to
flip that switch i know it's it's it was
it was tough and when i was reading the
script i would there was like certain
scenes where i was really
uh nervous nervous about doing because
like you said it's not it's not coming
up organically there's nothing that's
leading you
you know to that that emotion or
anything so that stuff was tough um you
know there's a couple times where i'm
just
i guess it's kind of like theater too
when you're staring when you're doing
the scene and you're staring out into
the audience and you're projecting
you know a house or your daughter or
whatever it is and they exist out in a
blank space
um yeah i mean i kind of had to utilize
some of that for this all right i'll
squeeze in this one last one it's a
little on the silly side i play would
you rather game a lot and the uh the
scene with the laughing in the g46 made
me think of this one would you rather
have to fake laugh in a scene or fake
cry in a scene
oh my god i think
the laughing only because it always
starts as a fake laugh and then it ends
up turning
into a real laugh because the like the
absurd theater of the absurd kicks in
and you just start kind of cracking up
so
fake crying oh my god i hope
i hope i never become a victim of that
but look sometimes you gotta sometimes
you feel it and then other times you
don't and that's called acting makes
sense that approach totally makes sense
to me all right they're gonna kick me
out of here congratulations on this top
gun and the offer i forgot about that
one already thank you have a good one
everyone thank you